I want to give you the idea the concept
that our brain is plastic the reading
brain doesn't exist it's created and
what you see here in English is a motley
overview of the circuitry there Chinese
kanji Japanese kana anyone here who
speaks or writes Japanese ah you have
the most interesting brain in the room
just so you know that brain is actually
using two different actually more than
two but two circuit that you see one for
kana and one like Chinese for kanji now
very quickly what do you see immediately
in kanji that's different from English
immediately you are not the most
immediate on the concept here is that a
logographic it's a slow go celebrate
it's gonna need much more visual memory
and putting symbols and meanings so what
you see here is that visual system in
the right hemisphere requires far more
space if you will cortical space and
here's the principle the writing system
will rearrange make the particulars of
that circuitry so your circuitry is
actually going to be influenced by the
writing system but that same plasticity
and here on forecasting that same
plasticity will make us change as we use
different mediums as well here's the
important principle for us to think
about what we do when we read makes a
difference in the circuit itself the
brain reflects the cognitive perceptual
and linguistic requirements of it that
brain is changing as we speak under our
fingertips
[Music]